she took out a mechanical pencil did and
then she was just waiting for it and she
went over and just like stabbed me
[Music]
to the day I was scrolling on Twitter
and I started seeing photo after photo
these little gray dots on people's hands
knees and feet even their faces it
turned out people were sharing these
permanent marks that only come from
means stabbed with a pencil house the
first I've ever heard of it but it
seemed like a really common thing based
off this Twitter post and I have our
time crossing the internet in general
but the amount of people who are
spotting with oh my god
that happen to me too here's a picture
of it seemed quite substantial I decided
to ask from the BuzzFeed office to see
if this has happened to anyone here and
lo and behold happened to way more
people that I thought I want to say it
was just the third grade and I dropped a
pencil and without looking went to go
pick it up but without me knowing it had
bounced back up on the eraser I kind of
met it halfway and it and it stabbed me
in the hand so I did it to myself
technically but yeah I went to the
nurse's office and they took it out and
it's just kind of been with me ever
since I got this in elementary school
with just a regular pencil I'm not even
sure what I was doing but I just
remember when I stabbed myself I was
10 and I was doing homework and I think
it was like very simple math that I was
doing but I got very annoyed and I was
laying on the floor doing my homework
I threw the pencil down to my leg and it
wound up stabbing me right in the thigh
the mark is pretty dark and I thought
for a while that like it was gonna move
like because the pencil really got in
there and I had to like pull it out I
thought that maybe part of it it broke
it off and it was gonna be in my body
and like float around somewhere but
luckily it stayed there but it's also
been like 15 years and I don't know what
to do I got this in middle school and it
was a very traumatic moment my life what
had happened was I was just a little kid
I was probably like 11 years old
minding my own business and the girl
nice to me is sitting in class it was us
middle of class find you she just like
turns to me and I think I said said
something that like she didn't agree
with she took out a mechanical pencil
did and she went over and just like
stabbed me and me being me defended
myself and I was like oh hell no that's
not gonna happen
it like totally punctured my skin and
when I recoiled I saw that a bit of the
mechanical pencil the lead have been
stuck to my skin and then if you thought
once that wasn't enough she went in for
a second time and she was successful I
thought it seemed crazy that a mark from
a pencil and stick with a person for a
lifetime but I did some research it
turns out that there was a name for this
specific type of mark Louisville tattoo
in middle school I was walking through
credit hallway and someone stabbed me I
don't know who it was but now I got this
forever tattoo
according to dr. Cameron rocks our
associate professor of dermatology at
Mount Sinai Hospital in New York he told
BuzzFeed news that calling it a pencil
tattoo is pretty accurate even said that
he was stabbed at age 8 with a pencil
and 37 years later he still has the mark
the stabbing leaves graphite particles
in the dermis layer of the skin if you
go to a tattoo shop and they put ink in
your skin that also goes into
dermis layer as well I've had this
pencil mark since 2008 I remember I was
in college and I was just talking to the
person in the library and my friend
comes up and starts talking to me and he
was sharpening pencils and I just see at
the corner of my eye like just a pencil
coming down like this towards my hand my
instinct was just to move back so I did
and he said afterwards that he was just
pretending to you know poke me but then
I actually moved my hand into the pencil
and the mark has been there since for 11
years now according to dr. rocks are
these pencil tattoos can be removed with
laser treatment but they don't have to
be and I thought I got a little piece of
the lead stuck in there because it was
one of those like really skinny and I
spent like two days trying to like push
out the lead but it did didn't it coming
out my pencil broke and I reached down
in my backpack and I didn't know my
pencil was facing up and I stabbed
myself with it and I'll say I had this
little piece of lead I also forgot about
it and so it's sealed though and then I
think like five years later I tried to
take it out by getting a razor blade and
try to
but it was too deep and so I just kind
of left it
[Music]